okay look if you're a short form
Advertiser please watch this okay
because your short form ads are just not
good and look they don't have to be bads
okay look just hear me out the evolution
of ads for short form platforms like Tik
Tok YouTube shorts Etc have been weird
for a while it has been basically just
scams and shovelware but now it would
seem that one of the more popular
approaches taken in the short form ads
nowadays is to try and mimic the
relatable Creator POV videos that make
up regular short form content so what's
the problem well they are the absolute
drizzling shits we know it you know it
it's why comments are always turned off
on them so what is the solution well I
think almost every ad would be better
off taking your existing ADP space
approach and modifying the elements for
vertical screens I know you already have
five and 30 second ad spots edited
together for YouTube take those crop and
adjust elements for vertical and you're
golden